I saw a photograph of your car I heard  about your car and so I asked to see a  photograph of it yes and you drive the  most this is in real life the most  amazing car I think I've ever seen yeah  it's a it's a American Jeep yeah but not  just any Jeep you really got this and  you drive it around with the top down  yeah you're making it sound weird look I  think it's a great it come that way it  had the eagle and the planet yeah I was  gonna buy a black one and I was like  signing the paper because like this was  my first like purchase after you know  getting the show and I was with my  stepdad and right before I was about the  sign he's like did you see the American  flag one out front and I'm like what  yeah hold on put the pen down went and  saw it and it was like this is it yeah  and like you know I texted all my  friends like would we still be friends  if I got this Jeep and it came back like  yeah we'll be better friends it's a very  very patriotic car very much  love it  you